the long and grueling hours of training
are cathartic for Yolanda Malika she
lost her family and her childhood in the
Congolese Civil War three years ago she
took part in a judo competition in
Brazil and stayed claiming refugee
status the new beginning was arduous
alone jobless and penniless now she's
putting everything she has into
qualifying for the refugee Olympic team
and perhaps to earn a living will she
make it to the Olympic team
someday in the streets of Rio de Janeiro
this district has a large african
community and Yolanda is on her way to
church with her friends children I'm
alone here in Brazil no father no mother
no brothers or sisters the church is
important for me it strengthens my heart
I attend every week it does us all a lot
of good
everyone in this church are refugees
like Yolanda that fled the horrors of
the civil war in Congo hundreds of
thousands have died in the conflict over
the past decades millions have fled
Yolonda spent 15 years in a Congolese
refugee camp in constant danger it
always makes me sad when I think of
everything I've gone through the last
time I saw my parents in my village I
was 10 years old and my mother was
cooking I told her I was going out to
play then the soldiers came and there
was fighting all around me
everybody ran the gunfire was
unbelievably loud I never returned home
Telemachus it's a bilingual chant
service Portuguese and Lingala Yolanda's
native tongue the past is behind us each
of us may begin again
a new beginning a better life it was a
yearning that drove Yolanda to stay in
Brazil after the judo World Championship
three years ago but the dream began as a
nightmare
for the 28 year old she was staying in
this hotel with the rest of the
Congolese judo team but the people in
charge fled with the team's cash
Yolanda stayed in the hotel for three
days before taking to the streets to
find something to eat but when she tried
to return she couldn't find her way I
was so afraid I couldn't understand
anyone I had never seen so many people
in one place I started crying and just
kept walking
she walked aimlessly for hours with her
money without her passport
finally she found an African hair salon
so bad the owner came to her aid and put
her up for a night I slept on the floor
I had no idea what to do I lay awake at
night crying I was distraught I didn't
know where to go next it was a night
that changed her life she decided to
apply for asylum in Brazil that was
easier said than done
Yolanda was illiterate and had no job
training it was impossible to find work
and for months she slept on the couches
of friends having fled civil war she was
now ensconced in Rio's infamous favelas
where drug wars raged I feared for my
life that I'd be hit by a stray bullet
Brazil can be very frightening and the
favelas are just like Congo there was no
difference It was as if I'd never left
one and a half years later she was able
to get back into sports an aid
organization offered her the opportunity
she had to travel by bus for two hours
to the training facility on the
outskirts of Rio Yolanda trained for 15
years in a Congolese refugee camp now
she's totally the best that Brazil has
to offer
this socially minded sports organization
has a reputation for turning out Olympic
champions on the floor Yolanda come on
her mentor you're Aldo Banaras he
coached Brazil's national judo team for
years including at four Olympic Games
well then why come on hold your elbow
like this he says don't put it away from
your body otherwise your opponent can
attack from underneath he's a great
coach and knows all the moves he has
shown me things I'd never seen before
judo has given me inner strength and
toughened me up it helps me forget all
my problems when I'm competing there's
no room in my head for sorrow and after
a long hard workout I can relax and
focus my thoughts on the future the
possibility of gaining a slot on the
refugee Olympic team has further stoked
he'll and his ambition her former
teammate papaw Lima seungah also fled
the hotel three years ago they are the
only candidates for the refugee team
from Brazil they'll only find out if
they've made the team shortly before the
games begin in Rio
we return to the streets of northern Rio
word has spread that Yolanda may qualify
for the Olympic Games she's gained a bit
of celebrity status here the hard work
is paying off where her biggest
supporters as her friend we can't wait
to see her compete there will really be
some fireworks she will be the Olympic
champion in Rio 2016 says another friend
for sure she's our champion a lot of
people in this area know who I am they
never used to say hello but now they
greet me and want to get to know me
better guys stopping their cars to talk
it's a great feeling a birthday party
barbecue with friends
the hours days weeks and months of
grueling training are paying dividends
Yolanda has qualified for a stipend from
the International Olympic Committee
$1,500 per month for nearly one year I'm
a good worker
a paid athlete it gives me a sense of
being hold I'm no longer a beggar
there's a Portuguese word for it clean
that's right
I feel clean and decent before I
couldn't afford a pair of long trousers
for church that was humiliating and for
the first time she can afford her own
apartment she got the keys two days ago
it's also the first time she's had a bed
of her own small victories that she'd
love to share with her family but she
hasn't heard from her parents and
brothers since the day she was forced to
flee her village the images of war
burned forever into her consciousness
look at these children their life has
just begun and there are so many
problems I had to go through it too I
should actually be happy and forget
about it but I can't help thinking about
my family I have no idea whether they're
alive or dead Yolanda hopes that her
parents will see her on TV during the
Olympics and somehow get in touch
a visit to the Olympic Park in Rio de
Janeiro the center point of the Olympic
Games the judo will be held here in a
few short weeks the world will be
watching along with thousands in the
stands
millions might see her on TV
Yolanda's Olympic dream is so close to
becoming a reality I'm already getting
goosebumps even though the stadium is
still empty the thought of competing
here in front of a huge crowd
unbelievable
but the moment is coming and soon it
will take place I'll make it positively
Yolanda refuses to think about failure
or what's to come after the Summer Games
no matter what difficulties she faces
one thing is certain she never wants to
go back to Congo
you